with the announcement of year five
season 2 in the accompanying trailer we
were showing what the season was going
to be all about same as the last there
are another four people for us to rescue
however the final is a target that we
need to hunt down and it just so happens
to be the recruiter itself in this video
I want to discuss who the recruiter
could actually be based on the current
characters in the story right now yes it
could be someone completely new that we
haven't been introduced to but there are
certainly a few others that we do know
that could comfortably fit into that
role Rogue agents are nothing compared
to the threats you are about to
face it's time you met the
[Music]
recruiter let's start with the character
model in the special report we got our
first Glimpse at the recruiter well to
be fair this wasn't really our first
sighting of the recruiter but I'm going
to dive into that a little deeper later
on in the video I love this character
art but something that was immediately
pointed out to me is that this model
very clearly conceals the gender and it
could just be me but it also seems to be
a little more slight and build than
previous models so while I've always
referred to the recruiter as a dude this
might not actually be the case and
certainly opens up a number of potential
candidates what does the recruiter do
realistically we only have the name to
work from as well as minimal prior
interactions with them watching from
afar while Jack Bonnie attempted to
prove his worth of course Bonnie failed
this test and division agents were able
to quickly dispatch him however the
recruiter didn't intervene they just
left disappearing in a cloud of blue
smoke the idea at the stage is that the
recruiter is there to find new soldiers
for the hunter program that Kelvin
McManus overseas we haven't seen the
recruiter do anything other than watch
at this stage so there really is no
reason to assume the hunter is any more
than just someone who potentially
coordinates and
recruits so what about many he has been
a little flustered lately and both times
we've encountered the recruiter in the
past Manny wasn't involved with
coordinating the mission but in all
honesty this really doesn't fit with
Manny's emo plus the recruiter was
actually helping Natalia with the
kidnapping of his people if you remember
back to the John yai Rescue It was the
recruiter who dropped off John at a
different location while we were looking
for him most of the people who were
taken were friends of many's and
obviously there was Mari who's been
losing his mind over with worry and then
there are his feelings towards Natalia
he passionately hates her
the type of hate I don't think you could
fake so a couple of small red flags but
many is incredibly unlikely in my
opinion I've seen M's name mentioned a
lot and she's certainly been acting a
little on edge since we got her back but
let's face it she's angry she sees right
through Natalia's plans for all of the
people she's been taking and on top of
that she's frustrated with Manny babying
her and also him seemingly being on the
verge of admitting defeat so she is
having to be tough on him to keep him
moving in the right direction I see Mari
has being the least likely to be the
recruiter like many she hates Natalia
and has been the one pushing many to
hurry up and get their people back plus
it's very likely that Mari had a quick
conversation with the recruiter at the
end of her
rescue take this put it in your ear I'll
let you know when it's safe to come
out these are division CS you'll be safe
in there I'll let you know when you can
come
out so now we come to Kelo before
everyone starts yelling at me and
posting Threads Online and complaining
about my hate towards Kelo I said I'd
run through the main characters and
she's next however I don't think she has
anything to do with this either yes
she's dodgy disappears at random times
came across super badly in the division
Recruitment and is generally just a
little bit Reckless and sometimes even a
little unhinged it's actually these
characteristics that somewhat prove her
innocence from what we've seen over the
years or months in game time kelo's
recklessness has nothing to do with her
intense loyalty towards the division's
mission she puts absolutely everything
she has into her role as an agent which
is why she felt a little bit left out in
DC when infrastructure was starting to
get established and there were multiple
people now starting to coordinate the
division and
jtf I don't think she has the energy or
anything left in her to be able to play
both sides of this
conflict or maybe it's this extreme
loyalty that is L to someone who
technically has more authority over the
division than anyone else
alive mcmanis may not be the president
but he is the Secretary of Homeland
Security and given that the president
has been killed and we really haven't
heard from anyone else in the government
it's entirely possible that Kelvin is
the next in
line so for someone with this much
dedication and loyalty perhaps she is
working with the person who is
technically the one person that the
division agents must report to since she
has been away she doesn't know who Mari
or all of these people are so it's no
bother to
her in saying that I really don't think
she would have the patience to just
stand by and watch all the fighting
happening right in front of her so who
knows I'm leaving Kelo as a
maybe VR mik or any of the people we've
rescued so far perhaps our isolation has
been making us paranoid because I've
seen a huge number of people that they
don't trust all the new people have
brought back to our sediment and that
there is a traitor within them this
could be true but I certainly don't
think to the level of becoming the
recruiter we need to remember that these
people have been in the castle
settlement for a long time before they
would eventually be taken away by the
Black Tusk
and some have even known many for even
longer amount of time before this it's
understandable that they're a little bit
on edge they were forcibly taken away
even though they may have been treated
okay there was surely a huge amount of
confusion and
uncertainty then if we look at the
individuals none of them really fit the
role John yai is suffering from PTSD he
is more than happy to be away from the
action and keeping busy in the
background Eva Garcia is too young and
definitely not the right person to be
recruiting hunters and this would be the
same with Lauren Fong Mitchell Billings
just wants to help people heal so it
doesn't make sense that he'd recruit and
potentially lead a bunch of
killers of course as of season 2 we now
have Cindy and she even taunted us but I
promise I like my new job better it's a
better fit so if you need someone to
recruit I'm your
recruiter but that's all I think this is
a taunt either from her or the writers
to throw us off she was overwhelmed with
being a division agent and took a step
back she still seems a little
overwhelmed after her work as a drone
controller much like Kelo I don't think
she has the patience unless she has
multiple personalities she would
struggle to keep it together in that
sort of position standing idly by as
people shoot each other apart while she
just stands there and assesses but
admittedly I haven't analyzed her
character too much that's the next video
as for vicam we still haven't rescued
him so we don't have the full story but
at this point I'm not sold on him being
the recruiter he was heavily involved
with Natalia in setting up her
organization but not necessarily Kelvin
and what he was doing plus he's still a
part of the whole hostage thing with
Natalia and while he's a tech geek that
could assist with the sort of stuff that
Calvin would want being looked after I
don't think it's anything close to what
Kelvin would like looking after his
Elite unit of
hunters and then we have agent Johnson
he was suddenly introduced to the story
with no buildup just this season many
apparently knows him but assumed him did
for to suddenly appear in the story like
this to the point of coordinating a
mission I can't help but feel but
something is off here I'm going to go
out there and say that something
significant is going to happen regarding
agent Johnson I don't know if that thing
will be that he is the recruiter or if
something else will happen but for now I
would definitely be keeping an eye on
him something just really doesn't feel
right I'm not sure if he has anything to
do with agent Brian Johnson who was
featured in the early cinematics for the
division 2 but also the extremist mice
Comics I'll have a link to my coverage
of these in the description
but if he is some very clever and Keen
eyed people on Twitter spotted something
that I myself had missed Brian Johnson's
model and figurine use a Tac 50 sniper
rifle on the side of this rifle you can
clearly see some markings with one
measurement crossed out in blue ink with
a new measurement saying 2,418 M and
then if we watch the latest trailer for
season 2 and slow down and zoom in we
can see that the recruiter is using a
rifle that has the exact same markings
on it pretty undeniable right well I
like to fact check and confirm a lot of
things and while I love the detail these
users have gone to to speculate these
things I unfortunately discovered that
these markings mean very little putting
on my own Tac 50 specialization weapon I
very quickly notice the
following so by this Theory I'm the
recruiter sadly I think this is more of
a case of the TAC 50 base asset holding
these markings and not so much an
indication of whose rifle it is however
I still consider agent Johnson as is
suspicious in my book and a hard maybe
for not just being the recruiter but
someone who could screw us over later
on earlier I mentioned that the trailer
shown in the Special Report was the
first Glimpse we'd had of the recruiter
but this wasn't actually our first
sighting of the target back in season 9
we came across the recruiter multiple
times throughout the final Target
Mission and then also again at the end
of last season so let's talk about the
obvious the model has changed
significantly from season 9 year 5
season 1 and now was this simply because
these were just placeholder models while
the close-up model was being created in
the background personally I don't think
so the previous also shows heavy
emphasis on using blue smoke which
doesn't seem to appear with this new
model at all so as per usual with any of
my speculation Deep dive videos I'm
going to throw a different suggestion
out there what if the recruiter is more
than one person what if the recruiter
we've seen in previous manhunts is
different to the one we're hunting down
in this one with the the red mask
sporting a more traditional Hunter frame
with the new one a perhaps more feminine
one although it's a bit hard to tell
with the cloak and why is this
significant well I feel like would
assumed the role of the recruiter too
specifically like I said earlier it is
only observed so far it hasn't joined
the fighting there is no reason to
believe that the recruiter can fight at
this stage just that it has good control
over the technology it has been given
and who has more knowledge of the
technology that the hunters use Black
Tusk and the division
CLA and Alexander Ortiz the founders of
Isaac Anna and Diamond AI systems that
are being used throughout this
conflict what if this couple were the
ones behind the
recruiters so far with The Descent comms
it's clear that the ores don't trust
Natalia or at least clear doesn't so
when all hell broke loose after the
outbreak they turned to someone who
could help protect them
Kelvin he would in turn give them a job
looking after his most powerful
troops the T's may not be soldiers but
they know more about the tech and AI
that keeps them functioning at the
highest level than anyone else does
maybe Kelvin sees them as the best
people to decide who is appropriate to
wield this power it would explain where
they' have disappeared to and it would
also keep them safe from Natalia as she
likely wouldn't have a clue of their
identities Behind The Masks this also
gives Kelvin one more foot up over
Natalia helping him keep the overall
control over what she is doing at this
point it's clear that he's using her and
her Black Tusk as a pawn in his plans
and having the two responsible for the
tech that everyone is using within his
ranks only helps solidify whatever it is
he's working
towards given how early it is within
this season I could be miles off here
but as always my goal with these sorts
of videos is to expand on what we're all
thinking about that is playing out in
the story regardless of how far I'm off
if I get you talking about it I consider
the video a success I know I've missed a
couple of obvious names like Garen Kina
but for the purpose of this video I'm
going to run with the assumption that
Kina is in fact dead it's not that I
wouldn't be happy with seeing Kena alive
and strutting around as a recruiter but
more than would prefer not to continue
the speculation on whether he is alive
and then add further speculation on top
of this around the fact that he's the
recruiter we have a whole season coming
up about him so I'd rather keep this in
check for now plus I think I'd prefer to
put time into a video that actually
expands on why I keeps saying Kina was
on to something before he died
and then there is Wally I um don't want
to fall into the Trap of body shaming
anyone so instead I'll pick on myself
after all self-depreciation is the
traditional kiwi form of humor Wally
being the recruiter would be like all
6'4 100 plus kilos of myself trying to
fit into my 5'9 less than 60 kg wife's
little black cocktail dress as
entertaining as it would be to watch me
try little Logistics just don't work so
I'm going to place her into the unlikely
category before I sign off I want to say
a massive thank you to Rob he and I were
actually chatting via Twitter DMS during
the year five season 2 special report
and it was actually him who planted the
seed in my mind on how the recruiter's
outfit helpfully conceals their gender
which obviously got me thinking before
scripting this video Rob is not just a
longtime supporter of the channel but a
massive supporter of the game and the
community in general like myself he has
seen a few more Winters than a lot of
you and his Support over the years has
been integral with keeping me and I'm
sure many others on track Rob on behalf
of the Comm
I would like to give you a huge thank
you and hopefully sometime soon I can
stop being such an antisocial prick as
my wife keeps telling me and finally
jump in on a game with
you anyway for everyone else thank you
very much for watching I hope you found
this interesting and if you have any
thoughts on the recruiter that I maybe
haven't covered please let us know in
the comments otherwise thank you again
and extremist mice extreme
[Music]
remedia
n